- What was your experience
like at McDonald's?
Was it hard like that?
- Oh no, I just was reflected
on something crazy I did once
when I was working there.
- Wait, I want to know.
- [Andie] Okay.
- Tell me, please.
- All right, it makes me sound terrible.
I promise you-
- I love your stories.
(Andie, Whitney and Kelly laughing)
- It was the only time
I've ever done this.
You may not believe it
but it is the truth.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I smoked some hash.
(Whitney gasping)
- [Kelly] Just once?
(audience laughing)
- What?
- And I went to work stoned,
but this is...
I'm old so we had to count back change.
This is before they counted the-
- [Kelly] You had to do it and I had to-
- Exactly, I had to count
back the change myself-
- You're stoned.
- And I was so stoned.
It was just unbelievable,
and the concentration it took
(Andie, Whitney and Kelly
and audience laughing)
to give people back the
right amount of money
was unbelievable.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And I still can't believe it
that I pulled it off.
I don't know.
I was like,
"What are they going to
find the end of the day?"
(Andie and Kelly laughing)
It was like...
I did it, though.
- Oh my God,
and your first time.
- Oh wow, it's painful.
- That has to be like...
That's a pretty big experience.
- [Andie] Yes.
- Not that I would know.
- I'm not very good at smoking pot anyway.
I'm just not good at it.
- I'm not good at...
I don't smoke anything, I'm a singer,
but I can't imagine your first time,
and then your-
- Oh wow, man.
- You were probably...
- Yeah.
- That person was probably like-
- Oof.
- what is wrong with...
She was like 10.
(Andie laughing)
- Yeah.
- 20.
Wait, can you give me that back?
Where was I?
(Andie, Kelly and audience laughing)
- I had to do that once, one time,
because the machine broke-
- [Andie] Oh dear.
- And I panicked.
- [Andie] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And she wasn't stoned.
- And I wasn't doing long...
Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was completely fine.
- I used to count back change in my sleep,
I'm telling you, it was in my head.
- We used to do a lot of things
before technology,
like I knew numbers, like I could call...
I knew everyone's phone number.
I don't know anyone's-
- I know, it's terrifying now.
- Yeah.
- You don't know people's
telephone numbers.
- So terrifying.
- I can remember my
original telephone number-
- [Kelly] Me too.
- From growing up.
- 817.
- Whoa.
- [Kelly] I know, well.
- [Andie] Yeah.
- Okay.
- It was...
I know, we're a different generation.